chaud ici c'est quoi ouais réchauffe-toi
avec le F mais ouais c'est bien c'est si
haut sur le FR non d'accord il
souffle super chaud a mais si tu veux tu
peux oh un peu d'air quand même ouais on y va
ça fait du
bien choisis ton swe
[  Musique]
sur un tank stupide, infiltrez-vous
[Musique]
quelques gouttes de vent
maintenant
[Musique]
encore ou faites comme tous les gros sh maintenant
ouais un angle plus large et ensuite nous ferons
des plans verticaux parce que ouais, à moins que
la pluie ne nous attrape
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
ouais
c'est bien ouais ok alors euh tu veux
faire ça, essayons de faire cette approche
ouais extrêmement
lentement comment ça ouais c'est
bien ouais allons-nous nous arrêter avant d'
eux ou allons-nous simplement continuer à
marcher et euh  Je pense que nous allons
probablement nous arrêter à cet angle où nous pouvons
voir euh le lac en arrière-plan et
tout tout beau et vert, je veux dire
la juste la belle lumière sur le
lac, je vais
bien et tu vas me dire quoi
lever  up ouais je
vous remercierai merci les gars de rien
Hey commencez
Rising s'il vous plaît merci prêt s'il vous plaît
voir la maison sur le prochain
ici W ouais,
continuez tous en avant oui
oui
[Musique]
wow ok vous voulez juste le tenir comme à peu
près là  ouais ouais gare-
le
[Musique]
toi ouais 202 Je me demande s'ils
tiraient de l'eau qui aiment la laisser tomber sur
ces maisons oh bien sûr, je n'ai pas copié à quelle
heure vous alliez retourner sur
l'herbe
[Musique] à
quoi ça ressemble  alors tu sais comme des
hogers, je pense que 15 sait tout, je
ne savais même pas ici oui, je vais
passer beaucoup de temps
ici, ok, très bien, euh, casse deux Tango
tête-queue, toi à six heures, il peut couper,
ok, oui,
ma'  puis faire quelques plans planants, des
plans statiques de gens travaillant ouais
dans ces autres groupes là-
bas, je pense que j'en ai déjà vu un avant, ok, c'est
la vitesse à atteindre quand nous nous
rapprochons comme vous, alors euh Ben commence à
avancer, je'  Je vais juste
m'incliner là-dessus puisque nous en avons
fini avec ça de toute façon et euh et faire
une sorte de vue en avion
euhhuh, je vais juste lentement le parcourir tout droit vers le
bas ouais je tire tout droit
assez près de
lui  donc
[Musique]
ouais, il y a juste une sorte de
qualité graphique cool dans ce truc ouais et
même ces lignes qui bordent ces collines ouais
comme les collines noires
et
ouais quelqu'un qui cherche l'enfer
[Musique]
Victor
wow continue tout droit, c'est
vraiment sympa ouais
[Musique  ]
ouais c'est une belle
photo nos adolescents marchent toujours dans
la rue ouais dans la rue marchant
à gauche de ton
ami je l'ai eu
tu trouves les adolescents
ennuyeux, ils sont si drôles même s'ils le sont
tellement ils sont comme à  du moins, quand je suis
là, ils ont tendance à être juste ce qu'ils
pensent, tout le monde est là pour les servir ou
quelque chose comme ça, c'est très drôle, c'est bien,
va dans la montagne alors ouais et
si on pouvait, j'aimerais faire encore plus, pas
plus vertical  mais statique un peu
statique
en l'honneur de Yan, il est plutôt d'accord que
c'était bien là où je peux trouver
ça ouais ouais
ok oh [
Musique]
ouais wow c'est fou qu'une
maison entièrement séparée parce qu'on dirait qu'il y a
une passerelle vers le bas  fais-le hé, tu vois
qu'il y a juste une limite et la
maison de droite est parfaite
oh
ouais wow maison intéressante
aussi au moins la partie terrasse wow
regarde à quel point tout est vert
ouais regarde ça juste ça
aliénation parfaite entre les deux
ouais quand
j'ai vu ce gamin je crois que tu as vu
quelque chose à gauche c'est possible je
ne sais pas où tu es non je suis à
droite oh j'ai vu quelque chose de blanc là-dedans
ou peut-être que c'était une voiture qui passait  par pourrait-il être à
droite, j'ai vu quelque chose de bizarre, d'accord, d'accord, euh,
pouvons-nous y aller plus loin, pouvons-nous refaire ça,
bien sûr, alors allons-y ouais ouais ouais d'accord et
survolons
euhhuh, en avançant lentement, je dois d'abord obtenir
la ligne, d'accord, d'accord,
CAD, nous allons donner  vous allez un peu vers le
sud, nous sommes au nord de 76 en ce moment et
nous vous suivrons après avoir
vérifié avec euh le moteur
ici,
est-ce que cette ligne de clôture nous emmène dans
quelque chose euh je ne vois pas que ce soit
n'importe lequel  autre
Burns non
ok un
peu plus
lentement et euh assurez-vous de ne pas
me donner de bon sketch s'il vous plaît je ne sais pas
où vous êtes si vous pouvez je
regarde juste vers la
droite là vous allez merci un peu plus
lentement
c'est
sympa  tu
commences, tu commences à suivre ou
ouais, je vais juste le suivre, euh
donc si nous pouvons juste, c'est une sorte de
passage à travers cette petite ouverture
là, j'espère que nous trouverons tout ce dont j'ai besoin pour
savoir où tu '  je pointe du doigt oh je suis désolé,
je suis vers 14h00, ok, je l'ai compris
et puis après ça, peut-être, fais la même
chose mais avec un angle moins euh plus large, mais tu
sais, les maisons en feu au
premier plan,
ok, tu dis à tout
tu es
accommodant non ça ne le fera pas,
finissons-en, es-tu
au sommet ici ouais ouais ce petit Archy
il va je vais pivoter là-dessus
oui lequel sur ce truc de petit garçon
ok regarde les arbres ouais c'est
bizarre, il y a des gens qui travaillent aussi, je
pense que nous avons trouvé ici, c'est dans le même groupe
non, ce n'est pas le même groupe ah donc nous en avons
trouvé plus, non, je vois ça, je
ne peux pas te donner plus de bonnes pédales, ok,
donne-moi tout ce que tu as
bébé, juste  prends-le,
je vais y aller, je vais m'en aller,
ok, laisse juste toutes ces maisons glisser
hors du plan, regarde, il y en a plus, c'est
génial, ça met peut-être qu'on va trop
vite ouais un peu ouais, toujours au top
ou ouais, je vais garder ça
là-haut, c'est un plan assez intéressant
ouais, nous le ferons deux fois, ouais,
ces gens nous aiment vraiment, il y a
un autre endroit sur lequel ils travaillent
ou ce n'est pas le même non plus  est-ce
non oh c'est le gars en bas de l'
allée donc je suis l'un de nos derniers ici
maintenant Ben si tu pouvais juste continuer à avancer
là-bas, il est dans notre dernière maison juste ici,
je pensais à gauche pareil là-bas ouais
ok toi
compris, nous l'emmènerons dans la
maison intacte, puis dans l'obscurité
ouais, nous pourrions faire l'inverse de cela,
oui, là, la lumière baisse, ouais, nous
avons besoin de chaque seconde, euh, ouais, allons-y, nous allons
partir de là, il y a du feu.  les moteurs
au loin laissent juste ces
maisons
ouais on peut commencer on peut même commencer
au bord du lac ouais ok
pause et
plus lentement oh ça H ouais ouais c'est
bien
merci oh
dérapages très
embarrassant
c'est pour moi je n'ai pas de
moniteur toi  je devrais en avoir un, je
sais, ch ouais, j'y vais maintenant, le
premier qui n'est pas bien frappé
[Musique]
ici oh partage, merci, merci beaucoup, on y
va, il y a une certaine
dévastation, a-t-
elle dit cloué, elle l'a fait, je l'ai entendue,
elle a une faute
gueule j'aime
rien de plus sexy qu'une
femme à gueule je devrais parler français c'est
bon je pense que ça sonne mieux quand on
ne sait pas ce que ça
veut dire
super on a pas de vent donc on peut y aller
doucement et au retour on le fera  c'est un
peu plus serré ouais
[Musique]
ouais, j'aurais en quelque sorte aimé être
plus serré mais je pense que c'est bien comme ça, vas-en en
faire un blanc et un plus serré
cette fois ouais, j'aime mieux le début de
celui-ci que l'autre
deux c'est bien aussi qui ne vous augmentent
pas trop
alors j'ai mon assurance incendie
récemment
pourquoi l'optez-vous euh parce que j'ai réalisé que
nous avons commencé à envisager de remodeler ou de
reconstruire l'intérieur correctement et j'ai réalisé
que c'était beaucoup moins cher que ce que cela
coûterait réellement
construire donc nous aurions été dans une mauvaise passe
si notre maison avait brûlé, nous aimons
être à court d'argent pour
cela maintenant, en fait, l'exception
de nos effets personnels serait extrêmement
pratique si notre maison
brûlait. Mai beaucoup de
travail  à part ça, nous avons euh
des plans architecturaux pour rénover la
maison existante, il faut tout recommencer là-dessus,
ok, je suis sur le réservoir maintenant ouais ouais et
bien tu sais ce qu'il suffit de laisser ce truc
signer cette maison, cette maison, devrais-je
descendre ou quoi que ce soit ou  juste comme ça,
devine alors nous allons y
aller et allons
montrer le moniteur à Ben je pense que ça pourrait être
bien oh tu vas bien ok des
enfants agréables qui jouent bien
ensemble j'ai toujours eu des notes élevées en ce qui concerne le fait que cela
fonctionne et joue bien avec les autres qui
sont  le positif H ouais et puis l'
autre est ne semble pas donner autant euh
ce n'est pas à la hauteur des
capacités apparentes et je dirais toujours bien à qui la
faute est
que ouais autre ils m'ennuient
h elle est sur M es-tu es-tu  j'aime
ça Dorothy ouais c'est bon tu penses que
si on se resserre un peu plus ouais
tu es fou non d'accord je vais le faufiler
non parce qu'en fait nous sommes nous sommes nous
arrivons ça se rapproche donc c'est  je vais le
faire
naturellement, qu'est-ce que
jce quand c'est
un
peu cool, le lac s'aligne derrière
lui,
ce que je dois probablement
faire
lentement,
lentement, regarde tous les gens qui sont
juste en train de surveiller là-bas,
ouais, oh, ils sont perdus,
ouais,
peut-être juste  comme survoler ici et rester
sur ça
[Musique]
ouais
oh et pouvons-nous nous rapprocher de ces euh
gens oui euh avec l'objectif ou avec l'
hélicoptère les deux ok euh je vais
zoomer maintenant ok ouais si tu  veux ouais
tu veux être plus vertical non non non
c'est bien je pense
ok wow regarde cette femme
en dessous ou oh oh elle ne l'est pas elle est juste
petite c'est elle le truc qu'elle porte
qui pleut un peu en ce moment est-
ce euh wow regarde  à
ce moment-là, l'hélicoptère peut-il se rapprocher,
bien sûr, est-ce que
je peux, ils viennent de partir ouais, j'essayais en fait de les attraper en s'éloignant
peut-être qu'ils vont
dans l'autre maison, ils sont allés
là-bas non, ils vont à la
voiture, ok, bien, euh, je peux  ne bouge pas
trop vite parce que euh j'ai enlevé le
volet oh
ok ce gamin est vraiment
content content j'ai perdu ma maison nouvelle
pièce je ne sais pas
plus serré pourrions-nous faire comme une photo comme celle-ci
et puis une photo plus rapprochée mhm
merci  Je suis censé dire que tu es le
bienvenu ouais de rien,
n'oublie pas tes manières oh
ouais je pense que ce gamin a commencé si
heureux,
plutôt bien avec ça, cette maison d'à
côté est encore une fois absolument parfaite
ouais
même les deux  ceux derrière ouais comme trois
ou quatre un
derrière lâchez prise pour aimer jusqu'à 27 ouais ouais et
puis euh nous aurons une photo comme celle-ci mais
plus près et puis peut-être comme une photo verticale
[Musique]
ok peut-être se rapprocher parce que je pense
qu'ils sont  je bouge ouais, ok,
paing, ne vous saluez pas,
les enfants idiots, je n'ai pas entendu ça depuis environ 20
ans NSP ouais,
idiot,
c'est votre temps dans les domaines ouais,
riche à vous, c'est tout le temps, j'en suis plein,
restez et priez-moi  petit gosse oh
c'est aussi je n'ai pas entendu ça depuis
longtemps petit gosse ouais j'avais l'habitude d'utiliser
ce mot
beaucoup j'adore parler de ton enfance
bien ne franchis pas cette ligne
[Musique]
les enfants oh là il
va
comme s'arrêter presque à  45
ok